let's talk about international women's
day uh first
i mean are you celebrating i mean let's
talk about black women in politics uh
for instance are you celebrating or is
there much much more to do
you know there is stuff to celebrate
when i first became a member of
parliament
there were just 41
women members apartment altogether and
only 21
labour women mps out of 650 mps
now in we have
220 women mps out of 650
and 104 labour women mps so there is
stuff to celebrate
but there is further to go
yeah and i mean are um black mps
being given the right jobs uh the
the you know the jobs of leadership
well you know we've got um david lammy
who's the justice secretary
um we've got marshall cordova whose
equalities
i think that both women and ethnic
minority mps
are being offered a much broader range
of jobs now
than they would have been offered say 10
20 years ago
and you of course were shallow home
secretary but
let's just talk about uh what's
dominating the news and meghan markle
and uh the claims that she's made of
racism
uh against the royal family what do you
make of that
well the idea that people were worrying
about exactly how dark her son would
be is really quite distasteful
and it's a great shay it's a great shame
because
when she first got engaged to harry and
they had their wonderful wedding
we all thought it was it was a sort of
new dorm for the royal family it was
really embracing
multiracialism but it seems that some
members of the royal family weren't
embracing
multiracialism at all because
if the one allegation and we don't know
whether
it's uh true if the one allegation
portrays the royal family as racist that
is incredibly
serious and that is incredibly damaging
because many people many observers
said that meghan markle was welcomed
into the royal family and charles walked
her down
the aisle and that there's there's no
evidence
of that racism what would you say about
that
almost from the beginning and you had
that fabulous wedding but from the
beginning
the abuse and the unpleasantness in the
tabloid major
was almost relentless i mean daily
there were articles and commentators
attacking megan for things
which other members of the royal family
happen to be white did without any
criticism but if
megan did that like eating avocado for
instance
you know she got attacked for it so
there was
a horrible media atmosphere out there
for megan
and you know no one is saying that the
entire royal family is racist that would
clearly not be fair
but like i say speculating about
how dark her child would be
is is utterly distasteful yeah that but
that is the one incident i mean
is it possible that women
uh are not embraced outside come from
outside and not embraced by the
royal family we don't have to go very
far
back in history to see how uh the press
have
have treated other women coming into the
royal family is it
is it a a women thing rather than a race
thing
potentially no i don't think it's just a
woman thing because
other women who married in sort of
family kate for instance
just did not get the relentless attacks
that meghan got
but it's true to say that it's tough
marion's the royal family but it's also
sad to say
the royal family doesn't seem to have
learnt anything
from what happened to princess die
you came into politics and you fought
for your beliefs
and you fought racism in politics
could there be an argument that meghan
markle would have been better staying
inside the family
and working herself for change within
that family
if this is the way that she felt about
it rather than
simply leaving and heading off back to
the states
well she didn't simply leave she was
driven out by the tabloid media
and if you've seen the clips of the
interview with oprah winfrey
she's a woman who enjoyed great pain and
great unhappiness is
they came close to breaking her and i
could understand that she thought that
for the sake of her family and for the
sake of herself as a mother of a young
child
she had to leave and get
some peace and some happiness
i mean there are all these claims of the
undertones of racism
in the coverage um the press coverage of
megan markel others
say other observers say that there's
been unfavorable press because of what
they see as the self-pity and
self-promotion
of a couple uh worrying about themselves
when over a hundred thousand people in
this country
are dying from covid i think that's a
ridiculous allegation
meghan markle got um she got criticized
for being photographed with her hands in
her pockets
when the queen had been photographed
with her hands in her pockets she got
criticized for eating avocados one
kate middleton had been eating avocados
there is a relentless pattern
of kate being attacked for things
which other members of the royal family
did
without comment nobody can really
look at the tabloid treatment of meghan
markle
and say it was fair and you can't
also not admit there was an undertone of
treating her as other other than she
wasn't
somehow in english rose and therefore
things that
other women of the royal family could do
she couldn't do without criticism
how do you think the palace should deal
with this
well i think it's like any um difficulty
in a family
i think that the family just has to get
through it
i mean the last thing you want is a lot
of tit-for-tat
um clearly megan and harry
had a very very difficult time now they
want to be together
as a young family without the kind of
relentless attacks on british media
and i think they should be allowed to do
that
i mean it is all very sad it is a major
rift now but
on international women's day which it is
do you have sympathy for a woman who has
worked her entire life in the public
service of this country
and has had great loyalty to this
country and to the work that she was
born to do the queen do you have
sympathy for her being dragged through
all this mess
well i'll have something for the queen
but if you saw the clips
from the interview both megan and harry
were
pains to say how much they respected the
queen and actually how fair
she had been to them this is not about
the queen
it is about i think some of the
courtiers and advisors
in the royal family it's what they call
the firm but none of this is about the
queen
harry and megan could not be more
appreciative
of the kindness that the queen has shown
and just on the point of mental health
that
megan uh raises in the interview do you
think the
i mean her claim should clearly be
looked into but do you think also the
allegations that others have made about
her
should be fully investigated
come on these allegations came up two
years later when they
knew that the oprah winfrey interview
was about to air
i think it just feels like a little bit
tit for
tat but it doesn't mean they have no
validity
yeah but why weren't they investigated
two years ago why have they waited until
48 hours
before the opera well that's almost a
separate question that should be
investigated too but should the claims
made again of bullying against meghan
markle be investigated
i deplore bullying
whoever it is from but i think there's a
degree of skepticism about these
belated claims against meghan markle i
think
the royal family has to learn from this